[Música]
Gustavo Petro se posesionó como el nuevo
presidente de Colombia y gobernará hasta
2026 en su discurso de toma de Mando El
izquierdista prometió cumplir con el
acuerdo de paz que pactaron el estado de
ese país y la antigua guerrilla de las
FARC
en México el presidente Andrés Manuel
López Obrador llamó a intensificar los
esfuerzos para encontrar los 10 mineros
atrapados por una inundación en una mina
de Carbón el mandatario viajó al lugar
donde se lleva a cabo la operación de
rescate
los demócratas de Estados Unidos logran
una pequeña Victoria en el senado con
una apretada votación los legisladores
aprobaron el proyecto de ley de
reducción de la inflación ahora esta
bandera del gobierno de Joe biden pasa a
la cámara de representantes
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en francés 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Colombia este domingo el presidente
Gustavo Petro dio inicio a su mandato
presidencial con una multitud en área
toma de Posesión a la que asistieron
miles de Seguidores y representantes
políticos de distintas partes del mundo
tras el final del gobierno del
conservador Iván Duque que dejó a un
país más violento que hace cuatro años
Petro quiso presentar las bases de lo
que será su gobierno enfocado en la
búsqueda de la paz total y la igualdad o
la defensa del medio ambiente Marta Moya
tiene los detalles
juro a Dios y prometo al pueblo
cumplir fielmente la Constitución y las
leyes de Colombia el centro de Bogotá se
vistió de gala para recibir a su nuevo
equipo de gobierno Gustavo Petro y
Francia Márquez la vicepresidenta
juramentaron el cargo en una plaza de
Bolívar abarrotada donde se congregaron
miles de sus fieles y personalidades
políticas y diplomáticas en su primer
discurso como presidente Petro hizo
alusión a su compromiso más firme y
decidido la paz la Paz es el sentido de
mi vida es la esperanza de Colombia no
podemos fallarle a la sociedad
colombiana los muertos se lo merecen los
vivos lo necesitan la vida debe ser la
base de la paz una vida justa y segura
una vida para vivir sabroso
para vivir feliz
para que la dicha y el progreso sean
nuestra identidad además el mandatario
mencionó a sí mismo su decálogo de
gobierno con un énfasis en la igualdad
con la creación de un ministerio
dedicado a ello que encabezará a Francia
Márquez la lucha férrea contra la
corrupción o la defensa de la
biodiversidad y el medio ambiente sin
embargo la búsqueda de la llamada Paz
total ocupó gran parte de su discurso y
se comprometió a seguir la
recomendaciones de la comisión de la
verdad para la implementación real y
efectiva de los acuerdos de paz tenemos
que terminar de una vez y para siempre
con seis décadas de violencia y
conflicto armado
yo diría con dos siglos de guerra
permanente la guerra eterna la guerra
perpetua de Colombia
se puede
cumpliremos el acuerdo de paz por
delante cuatro años donde las
negociaciones y las políticas de
sometimiento con los grupos armados
ilegales la reforma tributaria o la
lucha contra la emergencia climática
serán Asimismo grandes retos a llevar a
cabo por el primer presidente de
izquierda en la historia de Colombia
Cuba recibió a Los profesionales que
enviaron México y Venezuela para ayudar
a extinguir el incendio en un
almacenamiento de combustible en la
provincia de matanzas desde el viernes
comenzaron las llamas luego de que un
rayo cayera en uno de los ocho tanques
petroleros de la instalación las
autoridades han reportado un muerto y
122 heridos
Cuba recibe ayuda aliada este domingo la
nación caribeña acogió la asistencia de
los gobiernos de México y Venezuela para
tratar de controlar el incendio en la
principal instalación de almacenamiento
de petróleo causado por un rayo el
pasado viernes en la provincia
occidental de matanzas a disposición tan
oportuna con la que se ofrece la ayuda
de inmediato del presidente López
Obrador y el presidente
maduro de México y Venezuela
respectivamente se comunicaron con Cuba
manifestar
su disposición de ayudar sin tomar en
cuenta ninguna condición sin tomar en
cuenta ninguna demora sin tomar en
cuenta ningún retraso hasta el momento
82 mexicanos y 35 venezolanos con
experiencia en la lucha contra los
incendios de combustible se unieron a
las tareas de extinción llevando cuatro
aviones con productos químicos
para sofocar el incendio por medio de
enfriamiento a base de agua y espuma
Esperamos que en próximas horas nos
lleguen más apoyos así como el material
químico necesario para apoyarlos este
incendio en la isla que ya deja más de
un centenar de heridos evidencia que la
pérdida de combustible puede seguir
agravando la escasez y los apagones
habituales en los últimos meses el
presidente de México Andrés Manuel López
Obrador viajó a la comunidad de las
agujitas de Sabinas en Coahuila en el
norte del país allí supervisa las
labores de rescate de los 10 mineros que
están atrapados Desde el miércoles el
informe es de Ariana villacorta
continúan las labores de rescate en
Coahuila casi 400 rescatistas operan sin
cesar para dar con los 10 mineros que
quedaron atrapados en un pozo de Carbón
el pasado miércoles en las últimas horas
lograron duplicar la capacidad para
extraer el agua que inundó el pozo pero
el nivel baja lentamente Porque mientras
el agua sale por un lado entra por otro
por lo que los socorristas aún no
consiguen ingresar a la mina lo que ya
tendí que ya hay mucho
más evacuación de agua
y aquí lo importante que la gente
preguntaba
que si ya era un momento de bajar
la coordinación Nacional de Protección
Civil informó que el personal que
trabaja en el rescate introdujo una
cámara en uno de los pozos para evaluar
las condiciones de la mina por su parte
la fiscalía del estado de Coahuila dijo
que había entrevistado a los cinco
trabajadores que lograron escapar de la
mina y que su oficina había solicitado
información al propietario del terreno y
concesionario pero los lentos avances
hacen que los familiares de los
damnificados empiecen a perder la
paciencia y las esperanzas si es difícil
es difícil
el ver tantos sentimientos de
preocupación de tristeza Coahuila la
principal región productora de Carbón de
México ha sufrido una serie de
accidentes mineros mortales a lo largo
de los años
en Estados Unidos El senado apoyó aprobó
el proyecto de ley de reducción de la
inflación una de las banderas del
presidente Joe biden el paquete de
estima 740.000 millones de dólares de
los cuales 400.000 irían para combatir
la crisis climática el monto más alto
para este rubro en la historia del país
300 mil millones se dedicarían a reducir
el déficit ahora falta que la cámara de
representantes discuta el plan Rafael
Pérez tiene más detalles
una victoria para la administración
biden el senado de los Estados Unidos
aprobó un paquete de 430 mil millones de
dólares para combatir el cambio
climático y reducir el precio de los
medicamentos entre otros objetivos con
un congreso dividido el proyecto de ley
pasó Gracias a la aprobación de la
vicepresidenta del país y presidenta del
senado los votos positivos son 50 los
negativos son 50 El senado está dividido
en partes iguales la vicepresidenta vota
afirmativamente y se aprueba el proyecto
de ley en su forma enmendada
para los demócratas este logro
representa un punto a favor para las
elecciones de medio término del 8 de
noviembre se espera que el viernes se
voten la cámara de representantes para
que inmediatamente pase al despacho de
Joe biden para su firma el mandatario no
tardó en reaccionar hoy los demócratas
del senado votaron para reducir el costo
de los medicamentos recetados el seguro
de la salud y la energía al tiempo que
reducen el déficit y hacen que las
corporaciones más ricas paguen su parte
justa el líder de La minoría republicana
misma connell criticó el proyecto los
demócratas han demostrado una y otra vez
que simplemente no les importan las
prioridades de la familia de clase media
solo el 18% de los estadounidenses están
contentos con esta economía dirigida por
demócratas la legislación ayudará a
Estados Unidos a cumplir su promesa de
reducir a la mitad la emisión de gases
de efecto invernadero para el 2030 y
reducir a los costos de los medicamentos
para el gobierno los empleadores y los
pacientes
previamente hablamos con Maximiliano
bello ambientalista y asesor de
políticas públicas oceánicas de Mission
Blue a quien le consultamos si luego del
rechazo de los republicanos a políticas
medioambientales este partido podría
recibir un castigo en las urnas durante
las elecciones de medio término
yo creo que puede ser castigado yo creo
que hoy día También estamos viviendo
como digo un cambio importantísimo aquí
en el país en el planeta como ustedes
saben también hay cada vez mucho más
conciencia que efectivamente los cambios
que estamos viviendo era la ola de calor
en Europa en estos momentos cierto
también una una ola de calor y la y
también las cosas que hemos visto en la
última semana cierto de inundaciones
históricas en algunos estados yo creo
que también hace muy presente que este
ya no no tiene que ver con un tema
necesariamente tanto de un protago
republicano pero sobre todo que tiene
que ver con la humanidad hasta que ese
Informativo en francés 24 Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]